you want everything
and everything is
yeah Jennifer Lopez's Thanksgiving with
hubby Ben Affleck is everything it's
about family and it's about love check
out the singer's cozy holiday with
family and friends it was just perfect
she shared this Montage of highlights
from the celebration including making
cookies with vocal coach Steve Mackey
posing for a few snaps with her sisters
is all about family and sharing a cute
moment with 14 year old Emmy my mom's
just like
she's amazing she's such a powerful
human being it's insane like I don't
even know how to
explain it but of course it wouldn't be
complete without a few pics of Ben what
can I tell you we're just having a good
time he's in the background of a selfie
with Emmy and in another sweet photo
with Jen's son Max everybody should be
as lucky as me I'm very happy I'm very
fortunate and uh
life is good the glimpse into the
festivities comes days after the star
made a major announcement JLo's
releasing a new album this is me now
coming out next year this is me now
this is me now
and in her surprise reveal she recreated
her 2002 project this is me then
celebrating its 20th anniversary this is
me then
[Music]
this is me now
included in the 13 tracks a song called
dear Ben part two we're super happy the
couple who rekindled their love in 2021
because he's so lucky it's not often you
get a
second chance at true love
we feel very lucky
said their eye dues in August during a
lavish ceremony in Georgia it's just a
dream come true since ETS learned that
Jen and Ben are essentially Inseparable
and feel like getting married was one of
the best things they've ever done they
are over the moon in love yes I did it
I found the person that makes me the
happiest I have ever been
quote they're really focused on settling
down as a big family and making sure
that everyone is continually comfortable
and happy they're looking forward to
making more memories together this
holiday season traveling and keeping
things low-key new do our best we need
to try our best another source tells E.T
the pair feels like they got to where
things needed to be and like everything
happens for a reason it's really quite
an experience I feel
like myself again
[Music]